all right another story here daily wire
the Mandalorian recently surprised fans
with two Cameo guest appearances lizzo
and Jack Black the two actors were
featured in Wednesday's episode
chapter 22 guns for hire
and so lizzo Jack Black appeared on the
Disney Star Wars show the clip of this
um
episode the scene with lizzo went viral
not for the reasons that Disney probably
hoped but let's let's just watch a
little bit of this
despicable Theft Auto
calling the stiffing slimy I beg your
pardon this planet is unrecognizable
since he arrived
I had a feeling you hated me I'm
disappointed in you commissioner you
served my family well but Captain
Bombardier is the love of my life and I
know his heart is true sure he's made
some mistakes in the past but who here
Among Us is not
is there no room for a little bit of
forgiveness in a galaxy so vast
I am sorry to have disappointed you my
lady
perhaps someday I can earned such
forgiveness
from your grace
perhaps
as for now you must live in Exile on the
moon of paraquat all right
and as for you who's watching lady
who's watching this I saw this clip and
I real I had to double check because I
honestly first thought it was a skill
that was like an SNL skit or something
and uh and then I verified no that's
that's actually the show like that's the
show it's that's what Disney is putting
out
it has the Cinematic quality of a
furniture store commercial like the guy
who made the ad for uh Bill's Mattress
Warehouse down the street from your
house is a more skilled director and
cinematographer than whoever's
responsible for this utter drick and the
actors in mattress commercials and car
dealership commercials are better also
than what you just saw there you've
heard me talk about how important it is
to have a VPN to protect your online
privacy but choosing a VPN you trust is
equally as important I like to do
research on my sponsors and I only
recommend Brands to my listeners that I
believe in and that I use and I use
expressvpn to actually stop people from
monitoring your online activity you need
to do what I do and use expressvpn think
about all the times you've used Wi-Fi at
a coffee shop Hotel even a friend's
house without expressvpn every site you
visit can be logged by the Admin of that
Network there's uh really you know even
an incognito mode this is still the case
expressvpn is an app that encrypts all
of your network data and reroutes it
through a network that's of secure
servers so that your private online
activity stays private expressvpn works
on all of your devices it's super easy
to use the app has one button you tap
the button you're connected it's that
that simple stop letting strangers
invade your online privacy protect
yourself at expressvpn.com Matt walshow
use my Link at expressvpn.com to get
three extra months free that's exp
ressvpn.com Matt Walsh show this is what
we get okay this is what we get for
mindlessly handing our money over to
these Studios who have been milking the
same franchises for decades and just
putting the same thing out over and over
and over again they aren't even trying
anymore they don't care they they hate
we already know that these Studios hate
you
they also they don't respect your
intelligence they think you're an idiot
and will gobble up whatever they spew
out
they know you're going to watch anyway
because uh because of the brand that's
all it is and at this point instead of
watching The Next Star Wars movie or
show you might as well sit for two hours
in your living room staring at the Star
Wars logo on your screen you know
there's no point in watching the actual
because there's no story anymore it that
doesn't matter all of that is secondary
it's simply about the brand you're
watching a brand and when you watch
these shows in these films now you're
basking in the light and Glory of a
brand
and so you might as well there's no
reason to just that's what that's what
Disney should do the next Star Wars
movie
should be two and a half hours of the
Star Wars logo on the screen or maybe
some guy or maybe lizzo sitting on
screen and just saying Star Wars over
and over again
as a story okay as I've been trying to
tell you this forever as a story Star
Wars is over
as a brand it's not
because there are still these these
drones who will show up and no matter
what but as a story it's over there's
nothing left
okay it's it we got every every
ounce of story that could be milked out
of this premise it's gone now
all right the utter is is dry it's all
been milked
this cow is spent a long time ago
and of course you know people will say
well the Star Wars It's the Star Wars
Universe there's so many other stories
we could tell in the Star Wars Universe
was I am always saying
no the star the Star Wars universe is
over but the actual universe
yeah the actual universe is Limitless
there are a lot of stories you could
tell in the universe it doesn't have to
be in the Star Wars universe
but don't let that stop you
uh these companies they hate you with no
respect for you they're not even trying
to make quality content but go ahead and
keep consuming it I guess why not and
I'll do it for this portion of shows and
move over to the members block hope to
see you there if you uh want to join us
you can become a member and use code
walls to check out for two months free
on all your new plans hope to see you
there if not talk to you on Monday have
a great Happy Blessed Easter God
[Music]
[Applause]